I notice that the Eisenhower mug that's
been on my desk for 22 years just got
broken somehow and so I'd like to get it
fixed can someone glue this can just
take a second can someone glue this mug
handle oh yeah sure thing mr. O'Brien
okay all right there you go
it's Larry Larry Larry Larry yeah okay
do you mind gluing that for me sure all
right thanks a lot
I just appreciate it thank you very much
Larry that's Larry Larry okay I didn't
really from them okay let's get to
business there's this viral video going
around that everyone's been okay well
anyway this viral video is going around
I wanted to show you guys cuz it's
really
Larry Larry can you come out here
oh yeah Mr Bryan okay what are you doing
back there well I'm just gluing your mug
back together like yes well that that's
cool but you're making a lot of noise so
it's very noisy oh yeah sorry I can make
less noise if you want it less glued
okay just do what you got to do but
could you hurry it up if you can
I've got a Mitchell Bryan and trust me I
know what I'm doing that's why they
hired me okay all right
i glue mug handles okay here's I yeah
there's this viral video that's why when
I bought the Bally
[Applause]
[Music]
here's your mug mr. O'Brien all glued
just like you wanted yeah forget the mug
what happened to Larry Larry's dead oh
my god we told him to take his time that
safety comes first but then Larry's
exact words were screw safety tonin
needs this mug ASAP
he was my son's Godfather okay wait a
minute how long did this guy work here
today was his first day
[Music]
okay what is it what is what is all this
mr. Richter we just want to thank you to
you and your family for all the
beautiful flowers and of course the
edible arrangement well you know it's
the least I could do for Larry's one of
the greatest mug lures the industry has
ever known without further ado please
welcome US Secretary of Education
Helen Beaumont thank you in addition to
gluing Hollywood mugs for over 30 years
Loren Jorgenson with a tireless advocate
for musical education through his
program toots for tots
Larry donated woodwind instruments to
over 400,000 students across the United
States today we welcome several Tooting
tots representing the Burbank School
District playing an original composition
entitled greatest mug guy ever
please note for most of these students
tonight is their first time picking up a
musical instrument and it's all thanks
to Larry
[Applause]
[Applause]
you know I'm sorry those kids are kind
of old to be called tots and I think
they should practice before you let them
on television I you're right this has
gone on a little too long mr. O'Brien
please enjoy this brief tribute video
sorry
[Music]
case within its mighty gilded halls your
eternity
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the guy just died and you have time to
make that thing we're always thinking
ahead mr. Dell okay we're gonna take a
break I'm gonna figure out just what the
hell just happened when we come back
Keith Urban's here
[Applause]
you
you